this is the biju this is the danger miss
malotte hundred assalamu alaikum peace
be unto you this is the same greeting
that Jesus peace be upon him he greeted
his followers with Moses Abraham and all
the messengers of God and we've greeting
you with that same greeting here today
on the Dean showpiece we wish the best
for everybody now there have been some
misinformation some miss troops
associated with this beautiful way of
light the same way of life of all the
messages of God that complete and total
adherence submission to the one who
created you it's a very beautiful way of
life so today my next guest is going to
help clear up some of these
misconceptions is going to help tackle
some of the miss truths that are out
there so you can get a better picture
about this beautiful way of life the way
of life as I said that Jesus practice
Abraham Noah that way of life that tells
you what the purpose of life is where
you're going when you died gives you
peace and contentment give you success
not only in this life but in the next my
next guest here on the Dean show chef
khalid yasin sit tight I'll be right
back this is the team
this is the things is the danger this is
the things that angel this is the piece
bien tu assalamualaikum things on what
up little lawyer but gradually now most
people they know who you are share
khalid yasin can you just for a minute
for those of our non-muslim the not yet
Muslims who are out there viewing this
and we really cater to them we really
want them to get a better picture of the
beautiful way of life that we live and
to share this beautiful message of peace
with the world so you've been out there
lecturing people delivering the the
message of the purpose of life used to
be a foreign former Christian is this
true that's correct yeah and and you
still follow the way of Jesus is this
right absolutely how is that is that is
that a my twist in the true for is this
not on a percentage for Jesus Jesus was
was not Jesus didn't appoint himself
Jesus did not worship himself Jesus was
following the Mandate of the Creator he
said if anybody wants to go to the
Bible's he says I can of my own self do
nothing but whatsoever I'm ordered to do
from the Most High that is what I do so
this best personifies the position of
Jesus Christ as a prophet and a
messenger and so it's his values it's as
the values of his mission and his
message that we are still affirm
confirming and attesting to as Muslims
and he was one of those who submit to
Almighty God who had the ultimate
submission and so and before him John
the Baptist and before him Solomon and
David and all the other prophets of God
they all submitted not to themselves but
the Creator so in that sense I took the
best values out of the faith system
called Christianity and I've retained
those values as a Muslim but we went to
another level it's like going from high
school to university if a high school
student didn't know about the university
it would probably be very grateful to
have a high school diploma but if they
knew about the University and the
benefits that come from graduated from
university everybody will go in would go
so that's the kind of way that we see
ourselves if we feel ourselves to be
fortunate by Almighty God to have been
selected or chosen or exposed to Islam
and as such we took the best out of the
Christian system and and we're Muslims
misconceptions and we want to clear this
because hopefully God willing and
they'll be less Islamophobia it seems to
be on the rise and education I think is
key and this is how then we can start to
develop true tolerance and understanding
and it's what the Dean show is about
trying to help people understand the
most misunderstood way of life out there
yet it's phenomenal that it's the
fastest growing way of life out there
today so one of the misconceptions was
we just covered right off the bat we
greet each other with peace that's the
same greeting that Jesus greeted his
followers with and we just said that
Jesus was a Muslim he submitted as well
to god that's what we do and some people
say you know these people are the
Antichrist how would you address this
well first of all you know that's the
first objective statement that people
make because somebody off has branded
that just repeating that but Jesus was
the Messiah that is he was appointed by
God Jesus was the son of Mary and that
made him he was born of the womb of
course he had a phenomenal birth nobody
has any doubt about that you know that
there was no earthly father for Jesus
Christ we also acknowledged that also
but Jesus submitted himself to God he
prostrated the same way we prostrate it
he wasn't prostrating to himself so
there's a lot of misconceptions and to
be anti christ is only a philosophical
terminology that has come recently Jesus
was not a Christian
Jesus was the Messiah so Christianity
was something that Constantine came up
with to to to to create a uniqueness and
a special determination of citizenship
you know that the people who follow
Jesus Christ will call Nazarenes that is
he was Jesus of Nazareth because his
message started out in Nazareth so those
who followed him from Nazareth along
those different paths and roads were
called Nazarenes now Nazarenes didn't
call themselves Christians but when
Constantine a pagan Emperor when he
adopted Christianity he forced the name
Christianity to distinguish himself from
the people that followed him it's a
historical thing we need to look into
but no we're not Antichrist in fact we
are the people that personify we love
Jesus Christ we support Jesus Christ as
Muslims within the faith of Islam and
the name of Jesus Christ is mentioned
more in the Quran than the name of
Muhammad peace and blessing be upon him
amazing amazing these are facts not
fiction that's correct terrorism
synonymous a lot of times with Islam's
you say as soon as you say Muslim people
put terrorism after that what you got to
say about this [ __ ] well you know the
word terrorism if you go back in the
indie dictionaries where there's a
merriam-webster Funk & Wagnalls you know
or the Harvard dictionary Columbia
dictionary you'll find that fifty years
ago are the word terrorism had a totally
different name totally different
definition but after 1948 their word
terrorism the first time that Muslims
were called terrorists was in 1948 so
what happened in 1948 that was the
criminal invasion into Palestine the
criminal occupation of Palestine and
when the Palestinians began to defend
their country as freedom fighters David
labeled as terrorists so from that time
until now Muslims the word terrorism
fanaticism has become synonymous with
being with Muslims well that's just the
multimedia that's the that's like the
kettle calling the pot black okay but if
we look at history I mean especially in
the last 500 years what countries have
personified the word terrorism that is
in future to other people's lines
slaughtering people displacing people
traumatizing people that's what the word
terrorism means okay so who has done
that what is the British mr. French mr.
Germans as the Americans is the
conquistadors and all those kinds of
people who have been including into
people's lands are spoiling and
snatching people's natural resources
displacing people and taking advantage
of people and so that's terrorism so I
would say that the 43 million people who
have been displaced by this kind of
terrorism in the last 500 years it goes
to say that sometimes the people who
call people terrorists are really the
ones who are spreading historically
terrorism the second thing is that
Muslims are called terrorists only
because people want to demonize them
dehumanize them and marginalize them
because when you've been dehumanized you
can do anything to a person if they
dehumanized you see if you want to
demonize people make them seem like evil
that means that whatever good they do
people don't but trivialize it and if
you marginalize people it doesn't matter
what you do to them because there seemed
to be trivial so this is what's
happening with with Islam but you know
God has his plan and people have their
plan and the plan of God always wins
we're going to take a break and we're a
pair before yes here on the Dean shell
Islam privates killing of innocent human
beings human life is precious
they're always be someone there will be
there to say something negative but at
the same time there'll be someone there
to say some positive awesome just hold
on to the Rope of Allah everything in
this universe rely I need a last minute
the Quran says don't kill women don't
kill children don't kill the old people
don't attack the civilians this is what
the Prophet Muhammad told us it will pay
you mock you know Allah said that the
Prophet SAW sudden never ever start a
war against I'm not afraid to stand
alone if Eliza I am not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stand alone if
a las vacas ah i am not afraid
you
why is our news media foaming at the
mouth when it comes to stories about
Islamic terrorists but not white guy
terrorists is that because Muslims are a
bigger threat in fact between 1980 and
2005 ninety-four percent of all the
attempted or successful terrorist
attacks on US soil were not carried out
by Islamic radicals but instead by
non-muslims mostly white guys so then
why the obsession is back here on the
Dean show and we're trying to clear up
many of the misconceptions so God
willing there'll be less Islamophobia
because Islam isn't anything that people
should fear is it should people i mean
fear this is the way of life that god
almighty wants human beings to live I
mean to acquire peace we're all looking
for peace and you can't buy a six-pack
of peace you have to go to the owner
peace so this is that that way of life
that we're living and we're trying to
share with others but unfortunately
there's some miss Troost some
misconceptions associated and I just
want to touch upon this point before we
go to the next continuing on with this
terrorism does Islam condone does it
condone action such as 911 because
usually when you bring up terrorists
people start to think about the Twin
Towers and you recently had the new york
subway bomber does this have anything to
do with Islam shape no it has nothing to
do with Islam and but we have to be
honest that perhaps in some of these
cases we can clearly see that there may
have been some Muslims either directly
or indirectly involved but Islam and
Muslims they're not saying got separated
too yeah exactly okay Islam is the faith
system that is perfect and complete
coming from God based upon scripture and
revelation muslims are those who make
the claim to represent that but you know
when people have been traumatized when
people you know have been oppressed it
can make them mad it can make them angry
you can make them crazy it can make them
react in different ways we don't justify
that but we say that a Muslim who is
angry frustrated are crazy can be
manipulated
and if they do things that are wrong
it's wrong wrong is wrong and right is
right but let us let's let's say that we
have to understand that a person who is
put in a certain position if you put a
rat in a cage if you put a cat in the
corner if you if you corner a wild beast
how they going to react they're going to
react instinctively so I say that there
are some Muslims who unfortunately have
been placed in those conditions and they
have reacted in a negative way but Islam
has nothing to do with that and in the
same way that the Oklahoma the Oklahoma
bomber okay he was a Christian a
right-wing Christian but we don't say
young similar Christianity has anything
to do with that I mean Hitler was a
Christian but we don't say that we did
Christian had anything to do with that
okay the conquistadors are devil
Christians but we don't say that it's
not that Christian had anything to do
with that so you know the the greatest
tragedies in the world were done in the
name of religion and unfortunately the
Christian religion but we don't blame
jesus christ for that so i think that
would be very fair people need to be
taken objective insight into the sources
of islam which is the Quran and the
prophetic traditions of the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
and we never found our Prophet peace and
bust be upon him doing any such actions
like that therefore Islam is not the
villain the Muslims are in this case the
victims now tell us also is it true
because you hear this next word that I'm
going to mention isn't it true that
Jesus peace be upon him in Moses and the
messages of God they call people to
adhere to this word right now can you
define it and explain it because then
people will kind of settle and when they
once they realize what this actually
means Sharia when you say Sharia they
think oh the boogie Mans come in to get
you we don't want no Sharia over here
but then Jesus the tablets that he came
with I mean Moses the tab was it wasn't
miss Sharia wasn't this divine law can
you explain this word yeah let's just
try to understand the word Sharia from
its origin in the Arabic language it
means to arrive at a watering-place you
see Sharia means a path it literally
means a path that leads to water and
water is essential for life so what it
means
context of language is one thing what it
means in the context of Islamic
legislation is another it means that
Islamic legislation leads to life it
leads to success at least to regulation
it leads to a divine guidance that's the
watering place of life so Sharia is the
system that should govern the Islamic
state and when the Islamic state
influenced the world Sharia had a very
beautiful meaning today are the people
that package words can make anything
that is beautiful ugly and can make
anything that's ugly beautiful so we
can't believe the hype you see we have
to go back and make an assessment of the
actual values and principles now I think
that Muslims should not be so naive or
ambitious so as to think that we're
going to bring Islamic legislation
inside of a society that over he has
legislation that's conflict of interest
we can't do that we bring the principles
of Sharia from our hearts and in our
minds but we adapt to the society where
we are why because we have to be good
citizens and practical citizens and
being good in practical scissors mean
obeying the law of the country that we
live in tell us also honor killings
you've heard this also there's no honor
in killing this is something that's a
cultural phenomenon has nothing to do
with Islam nothing to do with Islam
absolutely nothing to do with Islam what
does the honour killing the people call
it so if somebody marries if a girl from
my tribe or my family marries somebody
from another tribe or family to keep the
honor we do something dishonorable no
that's criminal that's cultural I don't
care where it's done in a Muslim world
it's criminal and its cultural and has
nothing to do with Islam we need to
separate that and put that to the side
period that's it on ok good I think many
of the sincere the humble hearted the
open minded I mean these are just
clear-cut answers and they make sense
but someone might have heard that you
know these Muslims are allowed to lie
takia they call her something tokyo
tokyo explain this what is this does
have anything no the props also said men
rashanna fillets Amina he said whoever
was deceptive or lies to us is not from
us so we don't lie
we don't deceive that's not honorable we
can't do that in the name of religion
except the prophecy awesome said in
maybe three cases you know if I become a
captive of war and the people that
captured me say where's your leader
where's your armaments I'll tell them
it's in that direction although I know
it's in that direction so we can
understand practical practical purpose
that we are legal to say we're liable we
can say we're allowed to say something
other than the truth in that case of war
another case is to keep peace between
two people I was a witness of something
I'm the only witness of something and if
I were to say the truth maybe I would
exacerbate the conflict between these
people so I say well to be honest I
didn't really see that or another one
you know in the morning you know when my
wife is kind of like disheveled you know
the breath don't smell that good and so
forth and so on I said sweetheart you
know you look the most beautiful in the
mornings you know it's not exactly
truthful but you know it's sort of like
something that we live with as a life so
if you want to call that not saying
exactly the truth we can do that but
we're not allowed to lie or to deceive
no Islam is a religion of truth and we
stand by the truth even if it means
losing our lives this is amazing that
even these details even when you can
exaggerate or you know to bring peace
between people there's exceptions to
these rules but in general you Muslims
need to speak the troof at all times all
times amazing amazing amazing continuing
on we're here with sheikh khalid yasin
and all we ask that you have an open
mind humble heart and the troop is clear
is very simple to understand tell us now
the next misconception people see the
woman in the veil and they say look man
you're pressing these women let her out
of this it's hot out there what do we
got to say well first of all beauty is
in the eyes of the beholder so if an
America women feel men like to see women
and g-strings and women see themselves
be beautiful wearing g strings well
that's that's their set of perceptions
that's their set of values we don't
accept that we say that's demeaning we
say that's exploitive but at the same
token that's where people won't live
their lives we have to be tolerant about
that at the same token there was a time
50
years ago when do we saw nuns walking in
the street and they were dressed just
like our Muslim sisters are nuns the
Catholic sisters that attached to the
church and they were wearing the hijab
you know they're covered from head to
toe and nobody whistle better nobody
said hey baby no because everybody
understood that this is a religious
woman a woman of principle so the same
as our women are they deserve that and
the thing I'd like to say is that who
would have diamonds and pearls and gold
and their certificates of deposit just
sitting out on their table in the living
room for the guests to see no they
wouldn't do that whether they have them
they have them somewhere in a safety
deposit box covered out of sight okay
because anything that is valuable is
kept covered and out of sight so how
women is our goal our pearl our diamonds
you know our certificates of deposit and
God has told them and put on a uniform
they keep themselves covered because
whatever's covered is unseen and the
value is there whenever you expose it
everybody has lost a value because it
becomes common so the women should see
themselves differently and we should see
women are women as differently and so
God has ordered them to cover themselves
but ordering them doesn't mean that if
they don't cover themselves somehow
another we should speak bad to them or
disrespect them it's their choice as a
human being and so people should put
things into context and not to label
people from you know media reaction
you've come to those who have
consciously submitted to the one guy the
same God of Jesus Abraham no underlies
the final measure the problem and peace
be upon them and hopefully inshallah by
hearing many of these miss Troost being
explained in their context coming to the
Muslims people are getting a better
picture and better understanding we'll
be right back with more he was your
holiday are seen on the Dean show sit
tight okay you've got your dream home
and you've got your dream car but you're
going to get old and things going to
happen to you in your life and then what
have you got at the end of the day is an
empty dream that has no real foundation
we are going to dine and we're going to
meet our Lord and he is going to judge
us it becomes an obligation for each
single human being to find out what the
Quran is Islam is telling us to stay
away from things which are bad for your
person embed for the society
ah
back here on the Dean show wish a
holiday scene and we're clearing out a
lot of the misconceptions the miss truth
about this beautiful way of life now the
next question that I have for you shake
is that many people when you say Islam
and they think that we're trying to take
people back to the Stone Age riding
camels you know when you become Muslim
you got to wear a term and look like an
Arabic Arab you know that it is not
relevant to today's society how would
you tackle this misconception well you
know hollywood bollywood Charlie would
or not it would you know that's Nigerian
TV or Chinese TV or Indian TV American
TV or movies or media they create
fiction and create fiction almost like
it's fact so when people say that the
Quran is irrelevant I say that how can
rain become irrelevant to a farmer rain
5,000 years ago had the same relevancy
it has the same relevance what rain is
just like revelation so the revelation
of the Quran which is legislation from
the Creator just relevant today but it's
people who have contemporary thoughts
people who are intellectual today who
have to relate the values and the issues
and the critical issues of today make
them relevant and the Quran is a living
book it's not a dead book it's not an
ancient book it's a living book for all
time because God knows the past and the
future and so it's up to us as Muslims
to take the verses of the Quran the
values in the principle of the Quran and
to relate them to finding solutions for
contemporary issues and circumstances
the time is so short and we just wanted
to clear some of the misconceptions
there are many and possibly you know we
didn't cover one or two that might be on
the minds of some of the people but just
from listening to some of these these
are some of the major ones so you made
sense of it and it's God willing having
some people were flat but now they want
to know okay all right what is it slime
calling me too what's the benefit of
Islam for society and me as an
individual you know if I accept this way
of like what what good will it bring in
my life well look I mean since the
economy
you know it's supposed to be one of the
number one issues unfortunately you know
it's made the number one issue by greedy
and materialistic people but let's just
take the economy since that's a major
critical concern of all people right
well look the Quran forbids us god
forbids us from doing compounded
interest transactions and so people
wouldn't what people would not be in
such debt if there was not being taken
advantage of okay bye compounded
interest and so if I were to say to
people listen if you just took a course
of islam 101 to take a course in islam
101 and after doing so what we'll do for
you is will take the debt that you have
that where you lost your house we give
you a house back we'll manage that debt
for you but for now on don't buy any
credit cards and allow us to manage your
debt without interest would you be
willing to take that islam 101 course of
course you would and if you found out
Young's I mean that that you could live
prosper prosperously you could have
prosperity then would you be concerned
with that benefit your life of course
you would so I think that this is a
principle of Islam Islam will liberate
you from debt Islam will liberate you
from debt and if people understood that
they could be liberated from debt they
would consider to become Muslims
tomorrow amazing amazing tell us now we
gotta go for that again for those people
out there who like what we had to say
and now the junk is being cleared and
they having a better picture what advice
do you have them to continue on and
which direction to go because you know
there might be some more confusion in
their minds what advice to give for
those sincere yes I say to your viewers
whether they are local people or the
national viewers of people around the
world that you need to once in your life
take a time to read the Quran the Quran
is available I had to go to the public
library or go to Google gaggle giggle
and download it and take a look at it go
to challenge your soul or wherever you
can read the Quran for a minute or for
an hour for a day you'll find that your
life will not be the same also look into
the life of the most profound human
mean in the world in the annals of
history the Prophet Muhammad peace have
been blessing be upon him I think again
when you compare him with any human
being in history you'll find that his
personification is like the moon in the
middle of the night that's what I would
recommend thank you very much for being
with us thank you started with peace we
end with these to the crater God
Almighty and everybody say Allah rewards
you thank you so much thank you song is
Leguizamo and thank you for tuning in to
another episode of the Dean show we hope
that you got to benefit we got to clear
many of the miss Troost they were out
there continue to join us every week
here on the Dean show for another
exciting show until then peace be unto
you in every individual will there comes
a day where they need to take a second
just to contemplate about line man I
wonder why am i living adjusted i'm
breathin my days the crease and god
please see me and give me the reason why
you bought me in this life the truth i
want in there sometimes you get so
depressed i'm stressed no control of my
soul like a hole in my chest can't sleep
at night so i drop it to the open watch
the stores while I listen to the ocean